bon des années tu as tourné à l'étranger
est-ce que c'est aussi parce que tu
n'arrivais pas à faire les films que tu
voulais en France il y a un peu de ça
c'est à dire que moi je suis vraiment
attiré par les univers fantastiques le
cinéma de genre en général et pas
seulement l'horreur ou le trash mais
aussi des choses un peu plus un peu plus
vers le merveilleux comme ça peut être
le cas dans callskin j'ai eu
l'opportunité grâce à garer sevans en
fait de pouvoir travailler sur Gangs of
London de produire papi chat de Mounia
medour et c'est vrai que de partager ces
deux univers complètement différents je
me suis dit bah tiens je pourrais écrire
un film en France qui me permet de
d'utiliser en fait l'expérience que j'ai
accumulé sur ces deux films qui soient
toujours mon univers mais avec je dirais
une maturité supplémentaire par rapport
à mon travail de mise en scène et ça a
donné farangle
tu fais ton taf comme d'habitude tu
changes strictement rien
donc ton travail au côté de gare et
Seven sur gone of London a vraiment été
déterminé en fait pour la mise en scène
c'est vraiment déterminant parce qu'en
fait j'ai vu sa technicité j'ai vu la
manière dont il préparaissait films j'ai
rencontré des techniciens incroyables
là-bas notamment à Jude power le
chorégraphe de combat l'action designer
que Gary s'utilise qui est notre action
designer sur sur farang et c'est vrai
que ça m'a permis de pouvoir on va dire
envisager ce film à la manière de gangs
of London quelque part donc finalement
l'expérience accumulée m'a permis de
faire ce film là qui est un film
français de finalement amener ce savoir
anglo-saxon sur une production française
comment on t'explique qu'on a été
longtemps à la ramasse en termes de
films d'action en France est-ce que
justement parce qu'on manquait de
méthodologie ou qui avait une certaine
culture qu'on n'avait pas on a quand
même fait des grands films d'action
français par exemple les films de Luc
Besson quand moi j'étais ado que
j'allais voir Nikita ou Léon je trouvais
ça incroyable après on va dire qu'il y a
une modernité dans la manière de filmer
l'action c'est à dire que ce que peut
faire garaisse Evans ce que peut faire
les Hong Kong et par exemple toy Ark
ringolam avec qui j'ai eu la chance
d'être stagiaire ils avaient une manière
d'appréhender l'action complètement
différent c'est à dire qu'ils étaient en
immersion dans l'action là où les
Anglo-Saxons comme Frankenheimer quand
il faisait Ronin ou j'avais pu faire
stagiaire aussi sur ce film bah on avait
une mise en scène qui était beaucoup
plus distante de l'action c'est à dire
qu'ils étaient beaucoup plus spectateurs
alors que les la culture asiatique
permet à la mise en scène de l'action
d'être en immersion de pas dynamiser
l'action montage mais de dynamiser
l'action à la mise en scène et c'est
complètement ce qu'a dit gérer Gareth
Evans quand il fait the raid par exemple
il y a très peu de coupes tout est très
enchaîné beaucoup de chorégraphies il
essaye de tenir le rythme du plan le
plus longtemps possible et c'est
exactement ce qu'on a essayé de faire
sur Game of London et sur farrang c'est
ce qui rend le film viscéral et
finalement à l'antithèse de tous les
blockbusters bourrés numériques en fait
c'est ça c'est à dire qu'on a essayé de
vraiment les choses de faire les choses
en live en permanence de pouvoir avoir
un sentiment de plan séquence de se dire
voilà essayer de
[Musique]
dans la dentelle de ce qui est censé se
passer ce qui fait qu'on a un sentiment
de chaos organisé nous on sait
exactement ce qui se passe et le
spectateur est c'est comme de la musique
c'est à dire on détermine une vraie
partition de l'action avec un début un
rythme un tempo qui nous amène à un
final qui soit qui soit éprouvant ou
qui soit libérateur pour le spectateur
c'est qui les réalisateur qui
t'impressionne aujourd'hui en termes
d'action c'est un peu facile parce que
c'est c'est mon pote mais c'est assez
Vans sans thème d'action pour moi c'est
un maestro c'est à dire c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui vit pour ça il a il a le
cinéma dans le sens et ça passion au
jour le jour et regarde des films tout
le temps il est tout le temps en train
de travailler enfin c'est quelqu'un qui
est absolument en immersion en
permanence dans son travail et c'est
vrai que pour moi c'est le plus grand
metteur en scène de films d'action
aujourd'hui j'avais eu la chance de
pouvoir travailler avec lui sur son film
Havoc qui l'a fait que Tom Hardy où
j'étais réalisateur de deuxième équipe
et j'ai pu le voir à l'oeuvre et c'est
incroyable moi je me suis bah tiens
essayons de faire ça en France essayons
d'amener ce genre d'expérience en France
pour pouvoir proposer expérience un peu
on va dire innovante sur sur notre
production française c'est au premier
film de genre qui sort en France depuis
un certain temps est-ce que c'est que ça
change de faire un film pour le cinéma
ou pour le streaming dans l'action et
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose de
différent ou pas forcément c'est à dire
que quoi qu'il arrive tu vas envisager
le film comme étant un comme étant un
film de cinéma c'est à dire que ce soit
une plateforme ou une série parce qu'en
fait même en série on envisage la mise
en scène comme du cinéma après c'est le
temps que tu as pour faire les choses
qui détermine quel moyen de mise en
scène tu vas mettre dedans tu fais une
série comme Gangs of London il faut
savoir que tu dois faire environ 3 à 4
séquences par jour donc il y a des
moments où il faut faire des choix assez
radicaux pour pas pouvoir multiplier
trop les plans et en même temps c'est
une super école parce que ça te permet
d'aller plus vite ça te permet aussi
d'envisager ta mise en scène
différemment sur un film comme pharaong
où on avait finalement pas un très gros
budget on avait le budget du film et qui
va allant à un épisode de Game of London
mais avec ce que j'ai pu apprendre
là-bas il faut savoir que tu peux faire
45 secondes d'action
quel est ton rapport à la violence à
l'écran parce que bon le film est
extrêmement violent et plus on avance
plus ça devient brutal presque pas
comique à la fin mais à côté guignol à
la fin qui est très jouissif bah moi je
vais reprendre juste une phrase
Tarantino par rapport à la violence au
cinéma il y a un jour une journaliste
qui lui a demandé pourquoi vos films
sont si violents et lui il a répondu
because est déjà fucking fun c'est tout
quand on fait du cinéma d'action on a
envie que ce soit un kiff pour le
spectateur en fait et c'est vrai que la
manière de traiter l'action et la
violence au cinéma pour moi c'est ça
doit être un plaisir de spectateur c'est
à dire que elle doit être jouissive
c'est pas une violence
répulsive ou
complaisante il faut que ce soit
jouissif pour le spectateur il y a des
films comme les premiers films de Peter
Jackson ou la violence était jouissive
elle allait vers l'humour en fait et
donc il faut savoir que la violence au
cinéma est chez Tarantino c'est
exactement ça elle est souvent jouissive
c'est intéressant de la traiter de cette
manière là combien d'entrer un film
comme Farouk doit faire en France pour
que ça juger estimé comme un succès que
la sortie en salle a été une réussite
nous le plus important c'est que le
spectateur prenne un plaisir à voir le
film après le succès d'un film comme
pharaong idéalement vu son budget ça
serait qu'on arrive autour des 300 000
rentrées ça serait fantastique
aujourd'hui le film c'est très bien
vendu à l'international il commence à
faire les festivals il a été vendu de
partout donc en fait le succès du film
est déjà là pour nous à l'Inter c'est à
dire qu'on avait à peine terminé le film
que sur le marché de Cannes l'année
dernière le film c'est vendu vraiment
partout et on était encore en
post-production on est déjà satisfait là
aujourd'hui on voudrait que le public
français se l'approprie pour moi c'est
le plus important ce que je veux c'est
que les spectateurs se disent voilà je
suis fier d'avoir un film français de
cette qualité là je trouve que le cinéma
d'action change en France il y a eu bal
perdu 1 et 2 récemment il y a eu aka il
y a eu il y a des réalisateurs qui
essaient de proposer autre chose des
films d'action beaucoup plus modernes et
merci comme tu disais tout à l'heure bah
oui il y a une il y a une vraie envie il
y a une génération de de mecs qui ont
grandi dans les années 80 90 2000 ou en
fait le cinéma international propose
énormément de choses on a grandi en
étant influencé par les mangas par
beaucoup de culture japonaises beaucoup
de culture américaine et à un moment
donné faut savoir que quand on est ado
et que cette culture nous marque en
devenant metteur en scène ou créateur de
BD créateur de médias tout confondus bah
ces influences là continuent de grandir
en nous et avec notre culture française
on sait les réapproprie et un metteur en
scène comme Guillaume Pierret je trouve
que c'est incroyable qu'il arrive à
faire des films comme bal perdu parce
que lui il adore tout ce qui est
mécanique et quand il le fait on voit
qu'il prend vraiment plaisir à le faire
et c'est un plaisir communicatif avec
les spectateurs et c'est pour ça que ces
films marche en fait je pense qu'à
partir du moment où on prend plaisir à
faire le film ça se ressent et c'est
exactement ce qu'on a fait on s'est
vraiment amusé qu'est-ce que tu penses
de film comme John Wick ou la saga John
Wick ou même Tyler Rex c'est film là
pareil ce sont des films de cascadeurs
c'est à dire que les metteurs en scène
qui sont derrière ces films sont
d'anciens cascadeurs d'ancien régleur de
de bagarre d'ancien action designer
parce que c'est un titre qui est
vraiment propre au cinéma anglo-saxon
c'est à dire c'est vraiment comme un
chorégraphe de danse mais pour l'action
mais ça va beaucoup plus loin c'est à
dire l'action designer il va pouvoir
vous permettre de chorégraphier faire
des propositions de mise en scène une
manière de filmer l'action et ensuite
nous on donne l'intention et eux
arrivent à appliquer cette intention
avec leurs équipes de cascadeurs et ces
mecs comme Tchad je sais plus son nom
exact
tu le diras toi parce que j'arrive pas à
le dire mais en fait c'est lui son kiffe
c'est de filmer de l'action en fait je
crois même que c'était l'ancienne
doublure de Brad Pitt en fait et de
Keanu Reeves donc en fait il était déjà
doublé en de ces comédiens puis lui il a
il a vu comment ça se passait il a réglé
ensuite leur cascade et derrière il est
venu avec des scribes d'action et il
leur a proposé comme il connaît très
bien ils ont accepté et il est devenu
metteur en scène de ses propres
histoires et je trouve ça super c'est
des belles histoires de cinéma si jamais
tu devais nous citer tes trois films
d'action culte fétiches tout de suite
c'est hard boy de John ou directement
parce que je trouve que c'est le le
maître étalon de l'action tout confondu
ce qu'il a fait à cette époque là à
l'époque Benny des années 80-90 à Hong
Kong il y a les plus grands films
d'action tous les temps ont été fait à
cette époque là et pour moi ouais
l'action qu'il peut y avoir dans heart
bold c'est un cas d'école c'est vraiment
extraordinaire ce qui a été fait ensuite
je dirais the red 1 heure red 2 de gars
seven c'est pareil c'est des prouesses
techniques hallucinantes et en terme de
mise en scène d'action pure j'ai jamais
vu ça avant et c'est vrai qu'il a il a
un style un univers qui sont
complètement indépassable à mon avis
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y a une
différence à filmer en France aux
États-Unis et en Thaïlande j'imagine que
c'est trois univers différents la façon
dont tout fonctionne un peu c'est pas
non non il y a c'est pas différent c'est
à dire qu'en fait les équipes sont
identiques c'est le temps de travail qui
est différent le temps d'exécution des
choses c'est à dire qu'on peut avoir les
mêmes intentions d'un pays à l'autre
c'est-à-dire que moi j'ai pu travailler
en France en Angleterre aux États-Unis
en Thaïlande en Asie un peu partout et
c'est vrai que en fait à partir du
moment on a une intention de mise en
scène qu'on arrive à la communication
équipe c'est la même chose de partout et
ce qui est assez marrant finalement
c'est les différences culturelles et
c'est apprendre à respecter son équipe
quel que soit le pays où on va tourner
et à partir du moment où vous respectez
votre équipe et que vous comprenez
vraiment une équipe fonctionne vous
arrivez finalement à obtenir ce que vous
voulez à chaque fois avec ce soit dans
tout pays confondus donc il y a pas de
sacralisation finalement d'une méthode
de travail ou d'une autre il y a juste
en tant que metteur en scène et en tant
que chef d'équipe savoir respecter son
équipe pour qu'il vous donne ce que vous
voulez en fait c'est tout je me souviens
d'une interview de Guillaume Canet quand
il avait tourné aux États-Unis disait
j'ai pas le droit de parler aux
figurants sinon il devient d'un coup il
devient acteur et il faut il faut le
payer autrement il y avait demandé c'est
pour ça que c'est pas des règles c'est
un peu une légende urbaine je pense
parce que c'est finalement moi je
m'interdis pas d'aller parler aux gens
sur un plateau et au contraire c'est à
dire c'est on est humain et on peut
parler à n'importe qui et à un moment
donné on a le droit d'aller parler un
figurant et il va pas forcément devenir
un rôle après on est dans des enveloppes
de budget qu'il faut respecter donc
c'est en fonction de la demande qu'on va
avoir oui ça peut arriver que si on se
dit bah tiens ce figurant là j'ai envie
de lui donner deux trois phrases à ce
moment-là parce qu'on est sur le la
création c'est sur le plateau que ça se
fait et qu'on se dit qu'on en a besoin
on va voir notre directeur de production
puis on lui dit bah voilà il est plus
figurant mais c'est négociation entre le
metteur en scène et la production ça
fait deux films que tu vas faire avec
Nassim qu'est-ce qui fait qu'il est
différent pour toi dans le paysage des
acteurs français là où Nassim est
différent pour dans le paysage
audiovisuel français c'est qu'il a une
mentalité anglo-saxonne et que c'est un
énorme travailleur moi j'ai eu la chance
de l'avoir sur pharaong c'est lui qui a
fait la démarche de me contacter au
début mais écrit sur Instagram alors je
savais pas du tout j'avais pas du tout
pensé à lui au début pour farang et on
se voit on se rend compte je lui dis en
plus que le film à ce moment-là est
certainement pour quelqu'un d'autre que
j'avais en tête cette personne n'est
plus disponible et ça s'est fait dans
les 15 jours et donc j'ai appelé Nassim
je lui dis écoute c'est le mektoub
est-ce que tu veux faire le film avec
moi il était sur le film d'Olivier
Marchal overdose puis il a tout de suite
dit oui et là on a commencé la
préparation et le film a démarré ça près
pendant novembre 21 on a tourné trois
mois plus tard on s'était rencontré fin
octobre fin octobre 21 donc en fait
c'est vraiment en une semaine ça s'est
passé ça et dès que physiquement il soit
prêt parce j'imagine qu'il y a une
grosse préparation physique avec les
combats depuis qu'il est né donc en fait
on va dire que la préparation physique
il a juste un corps physiquement qui est
hallucinant il le travaille en
permanence donc ce qui fait que quoi
qu'il arrive il est prêt pour tous les
rôles et ça c'est génial parce que pour
ça il a une vraie mentalité
anglo-saxonne sur sa manière de se
préparer physiquement il est toujours
prêt si son téléphone sonne demain il
sera prêt et c'est quelqu'un qui
travaille énormément qui pousse les
autres à travailler énormément aussi
parce qu'il est très perfectionniste et
c'est génial pour un metteur en scène
parce qu'il vous challenge il vous
pousse à être meilleur et moi j'ai adoré
l'expérience avec Nassim parce qu'il m'a
poussé à me mettre en me remettre en
question sur des séquences à pousser le
scénario à pousser la lecture à pousser
le travail des chorégraphes a aussi
remettre en question l'action quand il
le fallait donc il va toujours aller
plus loin et il veut absolument faire
toutes ces cascades lui-même même si
Jude de temps en temps lui disait non
non tu passes pas au-dessus de la
barrière là parce que tu peux te blesser
mais il y a quand même il se faisait un
peu engueuler il y a des moments où il
affronte des vrais combattants c'est ça
exactement
détail le combat de boxe thaï comme
Nassim a été à combattu en tant que
boxer thaï on s'est dit bah tiens ça
serait intéressant qu'on fasse un vrai
combat de boxe thaï avec des vrais
champions et donc Nassim est arrivé face
à eux et les coûts étaient réellement
portés ils y sont vraiment allés et on
avait notre cadreur qui était au milieu
de du combat et je voulais quelque chose
de très immersif et là il s'est un peu
fait mal à un moment donné il me dit
ouais ouais il faut que mais lui il a
envoyé pas mal aussi donc là tu tournes
ton deuxième film avec lui exact qui est
un film de requin exactement les Jeux
Olympiques c'est ça non non non non
alors attention
fake news en fait c'est pour moi tout ce
que je peux dire sur ce film de requin
c'est que c'est une fable écologique qui
parle de notre humanité qui parle d'une
espèce de requin en particulier qui
finalement vont être dysfonctionnel à
cause de nous et Nassim joue le rôle
d'un des chefs de la brigade fluviale de
Paris qui va devoir gérer le problème
c'est un film qui sortira sur une
plateforme c'est ça non oui ça sort sur
Netflix l'année prochaine
certainement avant les JO parce que ça
se passe un peu avant les JO dans
l'histoire dernière question c'est un
gros challenge de faire un film de
requin parce que il y en a pas beaucoup
qui sont très bons vraiment enfin c'est
un gros challenge et en même temps c'est
un genre auquel j'avais envie de me
frotter parce que bah voilà Joe's on va
dire que c'est un des films fondateurs
de qui m'a donné envie de raconter des
histoires qui m'a donné envie de faire
du cinéma et je me suis dit bah tiens
essayons de d'appréhender ce genre là
mais pas comme de la Shark exploitation
essayons de l'appréhender vraiment comme
un film catastrophe comme un film de
science-fiction presque et c'est vrai
que le film finalement il se rapproche
plus de zehaust ou aliens que de Jones
tout ce que je veux dire bon ben merci
beaucoup merci à vous merci